lyon excusé aujourd'hui on se trouve
surface nat après 10,4 c'est le dernier
défaut en date et freddy l'on va faire
nouvelle partie c'est parti cinq jours
avant la fête
ça commence direct ok qu'est ce qu'il a
fait cette fois il vous a encore
enfermés dans votre chambre
ah oui là ça se passe dans une maison
chez nous carrément ne soit pas effrayée
je suis là avec toi
ah bah ça va alors si à toulouse qui a
tout les bourses autour de moi tout va
bien je me barre par où je vienne dans
l'île mais non aidez moi à lever tous à
ça fait de la peine quand même demain
est un autre jour
ouais ok c'est parti [ __ ] on descend
le quatrième alors là moi je suis là je
pense que je vais vraiment là
d'horribles s'installent dans une maison
nuit à cette fois il se passe quoi on a
un garde de la maison au fond regarder
derrière soi on peut fermer les portes
avec chiffres utilisés la lampe torche
avec contrôle clic earth to run to the
doors à je peux courir jusqu'à la porte
ok quand je suis à la porte je dois
faire attention si j'entends quelque
chose respirer je dois la ferme et au
hockey et là hop je peux reconnaître
jusqu'à mon lit ok donc je vois tout le
temps de chez qui les porte à temps et
je dois checker quoi wadia même là
dedans on en met mec donc et à la
capitale à la petite référence sur la
comprise elle fait pas plaisir voilà
comprise c'est incroyable tout ce qu'il
faut regarder la la la et là il faut que
je mette le sont forts pour entendre la
respiration en fait de ce nuage peut pas
mettre que sont pas forts et pas avoir
peur non en hôpital je sens qu'un jour
ça va mal se passer quand on va faire ça
mais voir une tête amont c'est pas
possible
attend en fait c'est un marathon quoi tu
passes ton temps à courir de porte en
porte et a gonflé car mon gars tu as
j'oublie tout temps derrière
non mais va pas y avoir un truc derrière
moi allez les deux heures du matin on
est plutôt serein à chaque fois je me
concentre pour voir si j'entends
quelqu'un respirer c'est horrible plus
tard y avait un bruit j'ai eu un vrai
bruit samedi la gauche a appelé la
gauche
ah [ __ ] je me suis cassé la voir un
seul cri bordel en alors déjà on sait
qu'il se passe là jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin et en fait faut mettre hyper fort
leçon pour entendre vraiment ce qui se
passe dans la maison quoi c'est hyper
fourbe
j'ai vraiment envie de kaka culotte tout
le temps mon nom c'est le cas au charme
on en sait lucas aux charges sécherie un
peu bavard mais pourtant j'aime bien
bulbizarre le rap du jeu d'horreur on va
l'appeler voilà ce petit rat vraiment
restera dans les annales à tout jamais
et je parle pas de touraine us c'est la
peur ça ça c'est la peur je sais je
m'excuse mais c'était danizan en fait la
cij ouvre la porte et que j'allume et
qu'il est là c'est un one shot quoi oh
oh là là [ __ ] vraiment il m'a fait
plus de courage pour faire ça que pour
aller à l'oral du bac je vous le dis
[ __ ] il est 2h s'avère la conceptrice
creamer thaler au plus ça nous arrive
dans les cuisines
j'entends parfois risqué et calyon
sélénia après les jo explique j'ai un
corps de l'âge mais si tu vois je me
sais rien je fais commence à l'eau salée
expliqué juste envie de pleurer
la bâche jamais vieux québec mais c'est
vrai ça ils peuvent arriver de demain
j'ai jamais dis que si je suis un
guerrier on regarde de loin en fait y
aura rien les cinq heures du matin et
jusqu'à 6 ou 7 heures je sèche amis je
sais jamais j'ai fait pour on a fait
plein de matches mais je sais jamais
voilà l'homme qu'on
au ces six heures c'est bon c'est 6
heures on s'en souviendra tout jamais
façon c'est le dernier opus de fanette
après dr année plus de voitures
souvenirs quatre jours avant la police
est alors du coup il se passe quoi je
peux tu peux partir cette fois tu sais
qu'ils se cachent encore je me barre il
n'arrêtera pas jusqu'à ce que tu le
trouves over there who
mais même à 11d me fait peur voilà je
fais comme lui foetus quoi utilise ta
lampe torche pour stopper les peluches
trappe on the xx tout skip to what j'ai
pas le temps je dois faire quoi c'est
terrifiant si on fait ça et qu'il a
avancé on va être terrifiés on sait pas
quand ils se lèvent à tout moment il
peut y poma timbrée à l'île lacroix par
terre je pense que je dois lui mais la
langue quand il est là il commence à se
lever [ __ ] bien sûr aux lettres à se
lever le pauvre waite
too bad oh non il a du coup c'est la
deuxième nuit en mode normal d'accord ok
on a raté on n'a pas une deuxième chance
moi je suis terrifiée mon gars mais toi
alors se trouve même pas peur c'est lui
limite si les impôts réconfortante
tu es content que ce soit des retours à
petit tu vas me protéger c'est cool je
comprends pas comment il ya un truc qui
peut aller dans ce dressing je comprends
pas il faut qu'ils passent par ma
chambre donc je le verrai il est une
heure du matin plus que cinq heures on
est totalement serein avec nous mêmes on
a peur d'eux aurait à une heure du matin
la paix règne sur le campus au messie un
chèque ici mais attendez les gars là
haut
est-ce qu'on peut refaire le mini jeu
s'il vous plaît le mini 2 et bien non
voilà la voix me nomme pas marché il est
arrivé d'où il était là vous pensez
bon c'est qu'il était là ou pas est-ce
qu'il était là et ce qu'ils étaient là
et on sait des tragédies qui le plaque a
inscrit 12 oct en héros ok je me barre
en plus ça met du temps à lui mais la
flash lite quand tu ouvres la porte
c'est fourbe en l'allégeant dit que ça
c'est le créateur du jeu avec sa mère
non ça se passe pas comme ça ici celle
qui tend l'oreille bravo cap d'agde à
l'oreille de dolbeau quoi oui bonjour 2h
du mat c'est l'heure où ils sont tout le
temps vénère d'enjeu
oh c'est quoi ce oui ça m'a paru être un
séisme un talus petit derrière on l'a
pas vu depuis longtemps
il a grandi d'un coup il a fait quoi il
est rangé mais peu louche comment ça se
passe la moitié ok ok ok ok le petit
fais-tu sur le lit à lhassa des gages à
temps mais voyez il est pour mon petit
quoi vous avez vu c'est son haleine la
la même mes cheveux qu'on fait comme ça
avec le levant 1h du mat il attaque déjà
il en forme
elle a pris deux trois cafés là vont
bouger je vous jure il est au taquet au
tac est aride à sa bouille pillay plus
là est plus là info je me relaxe
merci popotin antistress popotin voilà
ça fait partie des rares mots que
personne n'a dit depuis 2006
en fait des jeux passés d'une porte à
une autre porte le mieux c'est que je
regarde derrière moi à chaque fois alors
c'est peut-être mieux pour vous mais
pour moi ça l'était pas ok mais c'est
moins en paix avec métro north ou s'il
vous plaît je trouvais là bas je me
retourne je le vois il repart ok faut
faire mais pourquoi mais pourquoi vous
m'avez fait ça monsieur le monde fraude
en manque de virilité copyright scott
carlton je te déteste
oui c'est gratuit au revoir à la source
tout fait de merde ça va mais le roi de
la vapeur carrément il est au dessus
bah vous savez quoi la légende dit que
tu mets des coquillettes sur ta tête et
tu ouvres la porte avec le souffle du
monstre et ben ça va cuire les pâtes
tellement c'est chaud et humide
ok et vous rigolez à cette blague on l'a
vu au quai 3 heures du mat relation
peut-être jusqu'à 6 heures ce serait
fantastique
ah oui là à béthune au yes no speak
english with this fucking monsters
allez go go go [ __ ] on croit à une
opération militaire sur les connaît oh
donc oui tu l'entends pas tu es obligé
d'allumer pour le voir c'est bon pensé
c'était là ça je me souviens pas dans le
doubs je me barre j'ai peur chambres
dressing c'est un petit monstre fois au
départ d une peluche minium [ __ ] je me
suis trompé de touche ou de fermer la
porte j'ai allumé la lumière
allez ça passe et ça passe et on n'y
croit pas tellement mes bons amis
l'appellent temps de chanter donc à bâle
il a chanté il est là et là il est âgé
entendu un bruit un jeton au d'accord
c'est ce qu'il a des choses qui est
d'écouter je te mets au hockey donc le
plat car tu sais qu'un trio d'okola tu
vois là pour bouger et la dombes but
offrait donc biscary have testicules
ignore mouse quoi ah oui on va pouvoir
faire la petite énigme à la ola là c'est
quoi ça sert c'est l'anniversaire il est
parti sans toi il sait que tu détestes
cet endroit que juste à côté de la
sortie si tu cours tu peux le faire
ouais je vais faire aller non dépêche
toi tu connais vers l'autre chemin et
trouve quelqu'un qui pourra t'aider
tu as un [ __ ] de paix de bien dans la
combinaison sans déconner ça faisait le
très glauque tu peux trouver l'aide si
tu passes à travers eux tu dois être
fort peu de courage a dans cette action
sont décodés demain est un autre jour
non ok en fait si on réussit cette
épreuve on zappe deux heures de la nuit
suivante
fauconnet riffaud konaré le mec faut
qu'on y arrive on a 60 secondes à tanger
des grilles et la [ __ ] j'en peux plus
nous devons faire preuve de courage du
grand courage de maîtrise sur soir de
maîtrise sur eux surtout pete a fuck you
fuck you feu
[Applaudissements]
allez on peut le faire j'avais la même
langue ces lampes à bulle quand tu es le
m2 dont il ya des bulles qui voit là on
s'accroche les détails de mer finalement
peut le dire j'avais même qu'à son sac
il est passé du tiroir bonjour monsieur
crochet comment allez vous pardonnez moi
mais j'aimerais raccroché elle était pas
mal mais avec avec la peur c'est vrai
qu'on rigole moins aux blagues sur ça
vous avez paris à mon avis hein c'est
pas pour autre chose parce que c'était
vraiment très drôle à la langue qui
clignote bouge pas j'ai pas le choix je
l'avais vu je le savais un raid fait pas
ça fait pas ça on t'a vu arrête rupture
cache-cache mais on y jouera demain il
fera jour d'accord quand les bêtes vite
que ya le long de ce couloir vraiment
feront passer un bac de lumière je suis
pas bien je suis pas bien plus alors
vient de livrer un message
[Musique]
je loupe délicate n'ont jamais ouvert
avant bonjour squeeze ici scott magnin
merci d'avoir joué à tous mes jeux y
compris le petit 4e qui est comme tu as
pu le remarquer très terrifiant non je
sais que tu es bloqué à la troisième
nuit comme dans chacune de tes [ __ ] de
grosses vidéos de merde mais c'est pas
grave tu as quand même passé les deux
premières à à grosse merde
bon ma mère si scott alors bon bah voilà
on a gagné c'est scott qui l'a dit ok il
ya plutôt marqué ce que je vous ai lu
météo et ben voilà les gens c'est déjà
la fin de cette vidéo si ça vous a plu
parce que franchement c'était une
superbe aventure les fans attendent
prédisent le mec a quand même créé un
nouveau genre de jeu quoi fallait pas
créer un nouveau genre mais il a créé
souffre à son style est vraiment cool
quoi ça c'est vraiment des bonnes
mécanique je trouve très bientôt tient
tout le monde merci d'avoir des pistes
[Musique]